after some unconventional really
unprecedented diplomatic moves the Trump
administration looks like it could be
about to achieve long-term peace with
North Korea which is amazing and
unexpected in the Middle East though the
administration appears from moving
toward a possible showdown with Iran is
this wise and could in fact feuding with
Iran in parallel negotiations on the
Korean Peninsula here's what congressman
Tulsi Gabbard of Hawaii had to say about
it we talked to her a minute ago
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard is a
Democrat representing the state of
Hawaii and she joins us now congressman
thanks for coming on you've been I would
say nonpartisan in your assessment of
foreign policy issues you're for some
you're against others connected to the
administration based on whether you
agree with them so given that what's
your view of what's unfolding in North
Korea well Tucker this is actually a
really historic opportunity that we see
unfolding before us right now important
to the people of my home state of Hawaii
the people of this country and to the
world where we have an opportunity to
make an agreement that will denuclearize
North Korea and help move us closer
towards peace you know whatever people
feel about Donald Trump whether they
like him or they don't like him this is
the time for people to rise above the
partisan politics recognize this is not
about Donald Trump this is about peace
for the American people and for the
world and the opportunity to make an
agreement that will finally end the
Korean War and bring about the
denuclearization of North Korea if we
fail to do this if President Trump is
not successful in this the consequences
would be dire for the people of this
country and to the world so Congress has
an oversight role here presidents don't
get to conduct foreign policy solely by
themselves Congress needs to be informed
are you confident that you're getting
enough information not just about North
Korea but about what is happening in
Syria for example or with our posture
toward Iran are you getting the
information you need to make informed
decisions about it yes and no but I
think in each of these cases it's
important for us to recognize what is
our of
active and how does it best serve the
American people this is why I've been
calling for quite some time now for
direct negotiations between President
Trump and Kim jong-un recognizing that
it's critical for us to engage with our
adversaries and talk to them not just
our friends so that we may achieve peace
and avoid more more war there are three
things that need to happen in order for
Trump to be successful in these
negotiations that will coming up that
will be coming up in the coming weeks
first of all it's important for North
Korea to have a credibility Trump to
have credibility with North Korea and
making sure that if North Korea makes
this agreement with the United States
gets rid of their nuclear weapons
program
that the United States is not going to
go in and launch an attack and topple
the North Korean regime this is the
reason why they've had their nuclear
weapons program as a deterrent to regime
change a few things need to happen in
order for that credibility to exist
number one is we need to end the regime
change war that we've been waging in
Syria since 2011 both directly and
indirectly and end our policy of going
around and acting as the the policemen
of the world toppling dictators that we
don't like number two president Trump
and his administration they need to
publicly acknowledge that Bush's
overthrow of Saddam Hussein was a huge
mistake
they need to publicly acknowledge that
President Obama and Hillary Clinton's
toppling of Gaddafi in Libya was a huge
mistake in that in that situation with
Libya we need to recognize publicly
Trump needs to recognize publicly that
this agreement was made with Gadhafi to
get rid of his nuclear weapons program
in exchange for the United States is not
going to come in and attack you now a
few years later that's exactly what
happened
we went and dropped bombs in Libya and
Gaddafi was toppled and and lastly but
perhaps maybe even most importantly with
this Iran nuclear deal that we're facing
right now with President Trump
threatening to drop out of it an
agreement was made between the United
States and Iran and other country
to end Iran's nuclear weapons program so
far
Iran has shown to be in technical
compliance with this deal for Trump to
just say hey we're gonna throw this deal
in the trash threatens the ability for
North Korea for us to make this deal
with North Korea North Korea to say hey
how can we trust that the United States
will uphold their end of the deal when
we've seen time and again that they have
broken their promises interesting on the
campaign trail the now president very
often denounced the war in Iraq and in
Libya but not as much since becoming
president congressman thank you very
much for coming for coming on is
interesting
those are thanks appreciate it